[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
what a lad so i put it out there to the
woodland instagram followers about which
tasman marco they want on the podcast
next and i got a huge number of people
wanting this young lad he's an ex nelson
college schoolboy star who has gone on
to represent the new zealand under 20s
and the tasman marco this season he is
without a doubt one of the biggest
characters in the game and he is an
absolute lad it is of course the man
himself luca inch welcome mate
hey jimmy thank you very much having me
on the show um
i've been avoiding it for a while
for obvious reasons
um
but yeah i'm really excited to
see what questions you've got for me
mate so many people wanted you on why do
you reckon everyone wanted you on so
much
um
i don't i i do know
some stories and stuff
things i've done
are you a bad man i'm a good man yeah
i'm a good boy
we will say you're going to tell all
today or i'll tell um a few stories keep
it pg yeah oh perfect love that
anyway you're already one of the most
downloaded
um you're already responsible for one of
the most downloaded episodes so far with
your we chat to darren and the prank how
was how was that what's your memories of
that prank um i was actually driving on
my way to um
the coffee shop deville's i was going to
have a catch up of good earbuds and
stuff and um i get a phone call and i
don't know what was going on
come up as a just the phone number
i didn't think anything of it and i did
meet a lot of people on um
my campaign so
i just read along with it because i
didn't want to be like that you know
what it'd be
like oh darren i know you
[Laughter]
would you have let him stay at your
house if your mum gave you the pass oh
yeah where's your there's a mater like
corey i'd let him stay
corey's a great man
but did the parrots pick you off was
that yeah
as soon as he uh started talking about
pets
i um
i knew something was fishy and um then
the parrot came under and i just knew
he's only one dude in the team
i would say that that's you mate
so good but you mentioned that your mum
was allergic to dogs or is that a yarn
just to get darren off your back or is
it legit
um
i still don't think my mum's allergic to
dogs
but she says she is but um
yeah
we had a dog back in the day and we got
rid of it because she said she was
allergic to her but i just think she
didn't want a dog so that was a true
story that you told darren yeah that's a
true story was that yeah so you bought a
dog and then you hit the i just sell it
yeah true heartbreak heartbreaking good
dog nice dog rottweiler oh yeah would
have been a big boy by now oh do you
miss him yeah his name is roscoe
[Laughter]
one day maybe when you move out of home
yeah be so yeah yeah well you get a dog
yeah i'll get a dog yeah oh true yeah
that's awesome one like roscoe would you
try and find roscoe or no i'll get one
like roscoe just similar yeah would you
name him what were your name roscoe
oh that's cool but
obviously you're one of the most um
happiest smiliest guys i've ever met so
have you always been like that
and is that a conscious effort to always
be so happy and smiley
yeah i just um
i don't really like being sad or you
know um
i'm just one of those guys that likes to
have a good time and hang out with mates
yeah i do anything for the boys you know
yeah
just one of those guys were you were you
always like that were you a happy kid
yeah i was a happy kid yeah yep um
unless
fighting with my brother that was an
angry kiss
[Laughter]
two levels really angry or really happy
shane winterton might argue i'm a
redhead i'm not
[Laughter]
oh that's cool i love it so you sort of
talked about being young
what was your what was your childhood
like growing up
um
i started playing rugby when i was five
um i had a pretty i got a good childhood
i got a good nice brother and sister
parents still together um
great family
got a lot of cousins on both sides
um
so it was really good for me and i just
went to my primary school down the road
and i got a good group of mates that i'm
still best friends with today sure so i
went to primary school with them right
through
and but yeah i started playing rugby
when i was about five
my dad was a coach
and went right through the levels
my dad used to rev some games and i used
to get sent off when he was riffing
my childhood and um
i do sometimes wish i could go back
because i used to get up to a bit of
mischief
of your life yeah the best times of my
life um
then i went to nelson college in year
eight yeah um i was quite a ch i was i
was slimmer and then when i went when i
was in college i
put a few kegs on did you board there
yeah i did yeah yeah i went to boarding
and year 11. okay a little bit later a
little bit later so um
was a day we were on the bus for two
years um yeah nine and ten yeah
um i wasn't the most
frowned upon kid at school because uh
teachers didn't really like me
why was that i've heard you're i heard
your hard work at school yeah i was um
i was quite a disobedient little kid
say that
a few teachers didn't like to teach me
anton will back that up apparently he
said that five teachers refused to teach
it
uh
yep that's true is that yeah so what did
what did you do instead of getting
teached by them um used to sit in the
principal's office for those for five
periods yeah a day
for a few periods a day yeah he used to
sit there and do my work
and then
yeah under under 15 so i started getting
into my rugby bit more yeah and then i
really wanted to make the um like the 15
a's of the 16s yeah and um so i pulled
my head in a little bit
and then um when i was 16 they wanted me
to leave school yeah so they were pretty
ready for me to um they sat me down and
said look we reckon it's time here to
move on yeah and i was like oh yeah
and then my uh rugby coach warren
johnston
legend coming yeah coming to the game
and um told me to pull my head in and
then i pulled my head in a bit at school
and started knuckling down and i changed
all my subjects yeah so i was only doing
uh three days of school a week and
working two days a week so i have a good
balance and um
then i just keep chipping away and just
keep playing rugby and learning and just
keep my head down and getting out of
trouble what sort of stuff were you
doing to make teachers want to not teach
you
some stuff
[Laughter]
a few things i've done
[Laughter]
yeah just uh yep good stuff for class
you know how was it what was your
average period like so you'd go in
were you just a nuisance from the start
yeah so yeah i'd go into the class
i'd usually be the first person to be
told off yeah
and then if someone else got told off
i'd feel like i would need to be told
off more oh yeah yes i just there's like
a competition it was a competition yeah
and what sort of stuff would you do to
get told off just just anything anything
yeah true i know the teacher yeah
um look at this this one time was a
class you know you can get that little
fart spray stuff yeah we like bomb this
classroom with this fast spray
the teacher came into the class he was
out of the class at the time and um
he's like
like smelly ground like
smell this real bad smell and i just had
the biggest grit on my face because i
thought it was the funniest thing ever
and um
the teacher removed us out of that class
because he couldn't stand the smell
and we went into another class
and we did it again
glasses
and then uh this is my science teacher
and then um
he sat us down
and the deputy principal came in and no
one in my class wanted to rat anyone out
so we sat there for like three hours
until the end of school oh
till the day they don't really know who
it was
so it wasn't me
oh that's one of the great stories and
anton also mentioned about your assembly
apparently you used to you got called
out on assembly for breaking constantly
breaking the chairs of people in front
of you do you want to talk about that
one
um
yep so uh nelson college assembly
um straight after
smoko time or morning fee
some people would refer to
um
we need to have these uh chairs that'd
be four four wide and um they had like a
little steel leg in the middle
and my mates would be sitting in front
of me and i'd boot the middle leg out
and then the whole chair would bend and
snap
and go like that and
me sitting on the ground i'll just be
you know impressing myself laughing
because i think it'd be funny
and then um
in front of the whole school the prince
would stand up and be like luke please
stand up and i stood up for the high
school
you sound like an absolute nightmare so
what was it like for you going to
boarding school
i especially was my life this year i
went there for one year before you get
kicked out yeah
long story short
yeah we did um i'm a foul house boy so a
lot of boys know that um
i hated barnacle and i hated
rutherford house with my thing um
did you try them though no i just
thought it was a bunch if i had a bunch
of weirdos on them
and went to um
foul and i got some real good mates up
there daniel dixon hi yeah stephen
mcclelland oh
and um
[Music]
we
yeah we used to get up to mischief
um
it was great best year's my life um and
then uh housemaster got um removed and
got a new house master and i just didn't
really enjoy it as much as i could have
but i did have a lot of laughs in the
boarding house and i really enjoyed it
is it true that up in the boarding house
used to um plug in a toaster right next
to the tv get a whole loaf of bread with
peanut butter and just chomp the whole
thing back
um
that was at home
i was younger and i was fatter
[Laughter]
a good day out you know did you actually
do that i did that one time yeah did you
or the whole life didn't eat the whole
life but i had a good majority of it
yeah yeah so it wasn't a common trend up
at the boarding house no it was it
wasn't
yeah a lot of boys um
yes yes we just bread and milk that were
at the boarding house oh yeah some of
the boys will know that um and so
everyone just have toast because yeah
sometimes the meals you know wouldn't be
the best and you just
eat toast and you just mow it back yeah
it's great and is that when you put on
your weight you talked about before um
when i was at boarding i actually lost a
lot of weight did you i slimmed down bit
toast diet yeah so i slimmed down about
105.
what were you like at 120 at what age um
16. oh yeah holy heck you're massive
i slept quite i lost quite a bit of
weight that um obviously got put a few
kilos back on since i'm back to a good
120 i'm 22.
same weight as you were at 12 yeah
exactly true man you must have been you
must have been fed well it was good yeah
but you are from a i know you don't
really talk about it and you wouldn't
really notice it but you are from quite
a wealthy family
um
yeah
yeah my family's um successful in their
business and um
i don't really like to talk about it but
yeah it's good um i enjoy it no really
good people so
is it something you've consciously not
spoken about or have you ever tried not
to come across as wealthy
um yeah i don't i just i'm not really
into that so like if anyone asked me how
to say no yeah just ignore it yeah
so yeah
yeah sure about you do live in a mansion
[Laughter]
oh you're so humble
so when did the rugby um when did you
start taking rugby seriously and at
school you mentioned
um being naughty and then warren johnson
having that word is that sort of when
you thought rugby could be
the life for you like a job um
for year 12. um
my goal was to try and make the junior
crusaders so they're under 18 camp oh
yeah and i was fortunate enough to make
it and then in the trial game
my old mate times tomorrow williams
dropped me and i had a concussion so oh
you couldn't play so but that's not good
[Laughter]
and your first 15 days i know you're a
bit of a legend at nelson college um
with the first 15. so
any highlights from your first 15 days
um a few of my highlights would be oh i
just i i've met a lot of people
different schools and that'd be my
highlight just meeting
new boys and seeing them go through
their pathways
and it's just great you know play with a
lot of boys that i'm playing with now
that i played with at school like anton
and taya and
you know all those boys that's great you
play rugby for the boys you love it i
love boys yeah and you're not shy of a
diesel either are you
yeah never turn down diesel
[Laughter]
and when did that start were you
drinking at quite a young age or not
really
you kicked on when you got to the right
age yeah not really i was i used to have
um
i didn't really um get on the diesel
with my mates at nelson college
in my uh school years yeah it only
really kicked off after my school years
basically on with my mates yeah um
through my school years
and um yeah so luckily they didn't send
anything in
so oh so you were drinking but with the
your mott friends not your um nelson
friend yeah yeah yeah true real separate
because i suppose anton doesn't drink
and he's probably your best friend from
nelson college yeah yeah so you two are
pretty like complete opposites aren't
you yeah um
we're complete opposites but there's a
lot of he'll say the same thing we've
got a lot of similar
things
we do yeah yeah
[Laughter]
you're very mysterious and also upper um
is it true this is another one anton
centen actually is it true you used to
do a bit of a side hustle and sell
pocket [ __ ] to asia
oh that's a this is a true rumor yep
i
imported
pocket [ __ ]
from china
and i sold them to asians in the
boarding house
did you make much money from them i did
yeah i doubled tripled my money so it
was great
to buy some stuff at the house shop
was it something you look to pursue at
any point because it was going so well
um
no because i'd leave them in my wardrobe
and then i'd go find them and they'd be
stolen so i didn't
it's just one of those things that
i'll just try new things and that's
about it so yeah i'm a bit of a
entrepreneur entrepreneur i like to buy
and sell stuff
is that something you probably would
have done if rugby didn't take over
uh maybe not the pocket [ __ ] but
anything yeah well
i like to work but um
yeah but on the side i always like to do
something different we side hustle
hustle going on yeah so what do you do
for work
i'm an engineer i work at um tally's
nelson on the wharf yeah and we work on
fishing vessels
so um it's great down there i've got a
great group of guys um a lot of mop boys
that are a bit older than me yeah i grew
up with
they work there so it's good and how did
you get into that did you is that what
you started doing on those two days off
at school i actually was building and um
in year 13 i did my acl mcl pcl and lcl
and
again rugby how did you do that um i
hyper extended it
playing mca springer oh what did he step
yeah yeah i left over the fullback but
he would argue that
i just forgot how to run
and then how did it how did that all
happen uh i went like that and my knee
went like that oh yeah backwards and so
i did i didn't really do the mcl but the
other ones but sure just got a strain on
it yeah just add in the mcl for a bit of
extra
so that would have been tough for you to
deal with because obviously rugby was
the whole reason you're at school yeah
it was your big passion at the time yes
i was um
i really wanted to make new zealand
schools that year and that was my goal
and i was fortunate enough to get a
phone call from um matt sexton and just
saying look mate you're in the mixer
really sorry here you know
with your knees so that gave me just
that
that little bit saying i was you know i
would have been in that you know in the
environment and so that just made me
really want to drive that new zealand
under 20 team and that's yeah just from
there but then out of school i really
started enjoying work
so i left nelson college after um
i did my knee and i started full time
working yeah and building or engineering
engineering and engineering yeah
and i went through a stage where i
didn't want to play rugby anymore yeah
just wanted to play club
and
i was fortunate enough to have a few
meetings and a few um
fizzy drinks with me mate mad dan and um
dan parents damn
and um
we had a few convos and i didn't want to
and i was supposed to be going into the
academy the year after
and i turned down the academy i wanted
to
just do my own thing and i was
doing some rehab with a trainer
fletcher matthews
and
i just didn't really know what i want to
do
and then um
i just keep chipping away and then
it'd be probably
at the end of club season
i'm just thinking to myself
you know just gotta if i want to do this
i gotta really i got to be in the
environment the academy and i took
goodie and i talked to um
dp and a few other people crocky
and they just said look mate you're just
gonna have to do it so i just i did it
and look it's the best thing i've done
i'm really fortunate enough to be go
through the crusaders academy
environment and um
especially with piggy you know and just
all those people around me
really drove me to be that better guy
and so i'm really happy for them mate
that's cool so when you did turn it down
were you thinking rugby is no longer a
career option or do you still thinking
maybe you will get there eventually yeah
i was thinking maybe i'll get there
eventually yeah but i was just trying to
make my own pathway but then um
it's just too hard yeah you got
you got to be in the you know the
coaches are there the physio's there
and it's just so much easier if you're
in that space and um yeah and i really
wanted to make that new zealand 20
stands still so i just knew it was my
best option
and then you obviously did so the
pathway to get to the new zealand
schools was crusaders under 20s yeah
first yeah um
yeah crusaders under 20. so
we had that campaign at the start of
this year yeah and um
it was good it was you know something a
bit different
first um super rugby under 20 team for
the crusaders so
um i was just you know with and all with
all my mates that i played with in
christchurch yeah they all mate jack
sexton he's a good dude
um
and you're just chipping away down there
and when we went up to the tournament or
just a whole new
ballgame for me yeah um
it was just it was it was great the
speed of the game was quick and
it really opened my eyes and then i was
fortunate enough to get selected of that
for the new zealand 20s did you get a
lot of confidence from playing against
those guys and playing in that
competition 100 yeah so if i didn't play
in that competition you know
it was just it was definitely a step up
and everyone was um really wanted to
make that team
so there's a lot of boys out there that
i knew would be a really hard
competition to get in that team
and then um
yeah it was just it got selected and it
was just one of those things how did you
find out and how was your reaction
because like you said you'd been this
was your goal for a long time and you
really wanted to make this side so how'd
you find out
i actually can't remember
i think i'm
i think
someone rang me and told me
i can't rid her
but um
i do remember
i just played a game of club and i got
yellow cards oh yeah tabi manson rang me
straight after the game
and i thought he was ringing me about my
yellow card but he wasn't
[Laughter]
you were stressing for a few weeks after
that yellow card
and what was it like going into the camp
obviously you got along well with a lot
of the boys in that side i know you and
corey obviously got along really well
ruben love a few others what was it like
for you going in there um i just went in
there and just just did me just was
myself
and the boys you know this and first few
days were a bit quiet everyone was in
their little groups
and then um
after that we started training together
and getting into a mix of things and
then all of a sudden we're just one big
group of boys and we're one team and it
was just great the um everyone switched
on we need to switch on and switch off
um tom donnelly yeah great man
he's one of the greats
he was he was great and just to learn
off and yeah
i really enjoyed being with all my all
the boys and with some great boys around
the whole country now that i can you
know talk to yeah so you spoke about
being yourself going into then just
being yourself is that something you've
always tried to do because i mean every
time i've seen you you're you're you and
you've never really changed even coming
into the market environment is that
something you've
been has that been easy for you to do
that
um i'll just
if anyone's gonna someone's like me i i
just i don't want to pretend to be
someone else yeah and um
so i just go in there and just be myself
and they like me they like me if they
don't then they can you know yeah
it's pretty cool for someone so young to
have their attitude so like it's not
that common a lot of guys are like
really shy stand offish until they get
comfortable in the environment but you
can go into any environment and just be
the absolute character weirdo that you
are yeah pretty rip [ __ ] bust
but the boys love it yeah you gotta you
gotta be doing that
so it's something you gotta do
and then what about playing obviously
you didn't have a world cup which was
disappointing for the 20s but you got to
have a few games and a few good hit outs
even got to play against the mighty
tasman marco yeah that was um
it was good i really in first time
putting on the black jersey and it was a
different experience
i really enjoyed it and all the teams we
played were world-class teams um
it was just first game was wellington
harlequin's the second team oh yeah yeah
and then um third and we played the
tasman team and that was my team that
you know i really piggy was watching and
all the boys were watching so i just
wanted to go there just you know kill
and you did you got stuck into your work
yeah yeah it's gonna get stuck in but um
every time i put that jersey on i just
you know it's just a different
experience
anyone on that side stand out for you
like anyone that you thought man this
guy is going to be good
um
there's a few good there's a lot of good
talent on that team we had a really good
back line yeah um
reuben corey napkins yeah
cortez you know our whole back line was
um and you know it was great and um
the old mate antoine great player yeah
um but even that have we got a great few
great forwards as well but um
you know who you are so i'm
not gonna blow anything up your forts
was josh lord on the side yep florida
was in there yeah i was gonna say who do
you think would be the first one to be
in all black but he's obviously done it
yeah he's done it
i knew josh lord had a lot going for him
he was one of our he was one of our you
know he's probably the and our food pack
was one of the biggest yeah um
and he's just his skill work and his
drive
and his you know his knowledge around
this game understanding which is uh you
know unreal never wrote a question i
just went to him
and um no it was great
so who's going to be number two if you
had to put your money on someone who's
going to be the next all black out of
that squad
well we'll revisit this in a few years
unless you know
it can be yourself
yeah i don't know i'm not gonna i don't
want to say anything
[Laughter]
fair enough and then from 20s you made
the tasman marco squad were you
initially picked in it um i was picked
as a development player so
just a couple week days a week i'd go in
and um yeah so
but
i knew after the 20s they um you know
said they'll bring me into the
environment as much as i can so
um
yeah it was tasman marco has always been
my team
i wouldn't play for any other province
um
my dad's a proud nelson bay's man and um
so i just really wanted to you know
stick a stick at it love it did you feel
like you were ready to play at that
level
um
when i was initially named i wasn't told
so um
i was watching the
we got a team naming and they put the
boys up on the board and
i was um when my name popped up
i didn't really know
what
a
to
do
i was like oh you know nbc
you know get at my work and then i got a
few messages and i got one from billy
garden yeah and um
he told me
i'm you know i was good enough to be in
that team yeah if you're selected that
means you're good enough and that gave
me a lot of confidence that's good going
into the game so
and that just stick at it yeah because
obviously for a front row you're
extremely young to be playing um at this
level in the front row so um what was it
like when you first got out there
just want to scrub
love it but you're a good scrummager
aren't you that's one of the strengths
of your of your game uh i don't know you
know
not gonna blow any yeah i like scrums
yeah scrubs are good for me and um
i can play both sides so um
it's just one of those things that um
one of my strengths so yeah how hard is
that to play both sides i know a lot of
people talk about how hard it is but how
hard do you find it
um
it's definitely difficult um
at club rugby i play lucid because we've
got sammy martin playing tight hit yeah
and we always tell each other we'll swap
at half time and he never wants to
swap so i just play lucy yeah but i'm a
tight
i've played tightly at school tidy you
know 20s 20 for crusader 20s yeah
but when i go back to thai dead from
lucid it's a whole new ball game
um but when i go from tidy to lucid it's
it's all good yeah but lucy the tight
head's a different story so tight head's
the hardest tied to her a long way a
long way yeah so have you been playing
tight head or loose head for tasman um i
did my first game at tidehead against
bayer plenty yeah in the um
non-competition game yeah and
i it was a bit hard to start just
getting my um feeling my rhythm yes i
haven't played tight in a long time
and then once i found my happy
happy medium then i was you know i was
confident
but it just takes a few scrums to get
into it
so how many sort of dark arts are in
there at scrum time have you have you
picked up many of those or obviously the
old experience guys will be trying all
sorts of tricks on you yeah well um
the funniest thing is i'll be at school
and um crockey
and cain haynes would come in and do
some scrums with us and i'd be playing
tight head and they're obviously both
lucids
and they'll teach me a few things oh
yeah and then they'll teach me on i'd do
it on them and then
they'd just destroy me
after that and they'd be like you know
just get up you know just give me this
[ __ ]
but yeah it's just
i learn a lot off all the boys yeah
tasman's great you anyone's an open book
you ask a question and i'll give you a
straight up answer and that's what i
love about it and how did you find the
shield game
um i just wanted to get out i actually
thought i was going to get carded my old
mate is he put a shot on someone oh yeah
and um
then i got called off on the bench and
then um i ran out there now replaying
the videos like i was looking over at
him and he was just had a big grin on
his face because he thought that too he
thought i was gonna get carted
and um
but that shield game was um unreal
experience for me yeah um i really just
wanted to stick into it
and i just got told just run hard yeah
tackle hard and just clean rucks so
that's all i did and you did it pretty
well
yeah and talk to me about the scrum one
of your scrums there was a famous
incident where you went backwards pretty
quick what happened there
um so we were going against walks bay
and
um
i went we won the hit and then i reset
my feet and i caught my old my
q-max shoelace
and my right-hand boot
and i was trying to watch the video i
was trying to get my foot out of the
shoelace
and i just knew
you swear on this yeah i was [ __ ]
has that ever happened before
yes yeah i have it at twenties oh tray
um is it always the hooker he needs to
tape up at shoelace surely no
um the hooker caught my sawani caught my
shoelace
and ripped my shoelace clean off my
boots i have no shoelaces but that was
just a training so it was all good true
surely you start taping up your
shoelaces both yeah all of you i think i
might have to yeah good call good
learning
and you've spoken about your um debut
are you a nervous guy on the bench um
no
i'm not nervous on the bench but i'm
i just want to get out there yeah and
just
you know get out of it you'd rather
start yeah quiet in the zone yeah on the
bench um
i just zone in at the game and i'm
tunnel vision so i don't really look
around me what's going on i'll just
watch the game and then just really want
to get out there and get stuck in my
work
how good is that and what's the what's
the plans going forward have you got any
interest from super rugby um
there is some options for me now um
moving forward i don't know what i'm
going to do yet so i'll just have to
think what's best for me and my
playing opportunity and
just go from there that's exciting eh
yeah so would that be like a pre-season
um sort of contract or is that to play
because can you even play at this age um
it's a yeah i've got a pre-set there's a
pre-seasons
and then there might be something after
a pre-season yeah so um i just gotta um
divvy up what i want to do oh
nice to have options yeah and you sign
with tasman for next year uh yeah i'm
simon tasman for two years two more
years two more years locked in perfect
and what are the plans like have you got
have you set much of a plan ahead for
your rugby career um i'm a new zealand
player through and through so yeah i'll
stick here as long as i can and then um
i don't know if i want to go overseas
yeah but um
i definitely want to have a real good
crack at super and um obviously the all
blacks yeah that's my main you know
super is my next goal i just do one goal
at a time
and then after i make if i if i make
that then my next goal will be the all
blacks
and then just stay as long as i can in
new zealand
i love it so what do you can you have to
do to become an all black what's your
biggest work on as a player
um for me would probably be my just
little micro skills and my
defense um
my ball my hand you know yeah skill work
yeah just keep picking that up and just
keep chipping away and just always in
the
air and the coach asking questions um
nailing detail
and just never be afraid to you know ask
a question mate you're going to go a
long long way there's no question about
that
and then after rugby is it to go back to
engineering because you obviously loved
engineering that much that you
contemplated quitting rag before it um
i'll go back and i'll finish my time um
but i probably want to work for my old
man my dad's a sparky yeah does um power
station stuff so i'll probably go back
and um
try and learn the ropes
my best friend's is apprentice so
he can teach me
and that's what you loved about it yeah
yeah just working with your mates yep oh
you're a lad okay obviously extremely
exciting player massive future in the
game and i have put it out to the
instagram for some questions
and wow luca inch so many questions came
for you first question a couple of these
we might not be able to ask but first
question
is it true that you have a lisp uh yep i
do have a lisp i used to have lessons at
school and um
i fixed it a lot i smashed all my teeth
out
when i was younger so my and i didn't
get them fixed for a while so it
sometimes comes out how old was that
11 11 years old so is that when the lisp
was created yeah
from not having the front teeth yeah i
dived in the pool and smashed the four
front teeth out oh geez brutal
[Music]
did it yeah what'd your teeth hit in the
pool
the ground
was it must be pretty shallow yep
[Laughter]
did you not know it was shallow
i don't actually know what happened i um
just dived in and
um
slid along the bottom and then somehow
just caught my mouth on the bottom
chipped out just like that crazy
and then what was that like dealing with
a lisp like going through college and
all that it's obviously
um
you used to get a lot of [ __ ] yeah um
but i don't really care i don't care
what people think or anything me so just
yeah you know got an issue with
[Laughter]
it's not a prominent list now is it nah
just sometimes it comes out yeah but the
boys still love to give you a little bit
boy's still gonna love me give me
oh good start okay who's your favorite
marco team mate
um
i've got a lot of good marco teammates
but
he's throwing through it'll be my anton
you know i've been through school with
him and
20's with him and i've done everything
with him he's you know been one of my
best mates right through college and
he's yeah just trying to go the same you
know going with that path with him so
it's exciting
i can say a lot more people good
teammates though yeah well as alex
nanceville he sent it in so i'm guessing
he wanted to be yeah
banks nank would be the next one
he's always a good laugh
but i have the sorry nick i've got to go
but you put a few votes in for next to
come on the podcast didn't you you
didn't actually know that i could see
who was writing the name and you put in
next about five or six times yeah i did
um i thought it's anonymous
it just comes up with luca
nank
but you changed tried to change the
writing of it like alex nankeville or
manx
just change that little micro detail
you're a good man of detail okay
do you measure in centimeters or inches
what for
anything
i'm guessing it's word playing your name
millimeters because i'm an engineer
i know where this is guard so i'm not
soaking anything
okay
how many toasters does your mum have to
buy a year
dan perrin put that comment and didn't
he did yeah um
one toaster this year we've actually on
a second toaster because i destroyed the
first toaster what happened to it um
it was before a marist game
at tea park i was cooking my toast
and the toaster wasn't working it was
only cooking one side of the bread oh
yeah yeah so frustrating and um half a
touch of toast so i got frustrated with
it and i um i threw the toaster out the
window in the rain
and then i got yellow carded
against
and they'll ring it it's because of the
toaster what do you reckon honestly do
you reckon that played a part in it 100
percent did it yeah yeah the toast got
it from the get-go true yeah so it's
pretty as warning signs if you ever
lose a toaster maybe
stand down a week or yeah just cool down
yeah i was i'm pretty on the red that
day so yeah jeez toast that'll get you
okay how was the nelson marlborough
rivalry throughout the first 15
oh
unreal i used to love it did you i hate
marlborough yeah
i love them now because they're my team
but
schoolboy rugby i hated them yeah and um
there's a few great boys over there that
i still really love to connect with
and um
yeah the rivalry was unreal when we
played them or
um at their school they'd come playing
us at our school
that just or everyone would get up for a
game so it'd always be a great game
um
i used to just try to smoke everyone no
doubt yeah
dirty in the mall
okay
um what would you tell a young luca
wrench back at school
um pull your head in or
yeah whatever the teacher said to me
mate when money and the other
they had no chance yeah
[Laughter]
okay
who's the one player you'd most like to
scrum against
one of those
one of those non
nons
and he's tied it and i want to have a
good crack at him oh true is he was he
the 20s big dog he was the israelite
you know he's a great guy did he start
ahead of you yeah yeah yeah
so there's a bit of a rivalry there
great scrummer yeah um but i'd love to
have a crack at them
yeah
would you back yourself yeah no doubt
yeah i bet myself yeah oh so there's a
little bit of a rivalry that's cool yeah
hey who's how you going to be playing
for um i don't actually know he's a
auckland boy so yeah
you know whatever true they're in
covert cap lockdown so disappointing for
them yeah now obviously you've struggled
you've had your moments where you
sort of
questioned yourself in the rugby game so
i'll be interested to get your
answer on this one one piece of advice
that you'd give a young professional
rugby player coming through
if you're a young player coming through
the mixer and
you've obviously been scattered through
school
um
even if you haven't been scattered
through school you know just keep
keep chipping at it and if you've got
coaches love to hear from you so
if you know a coach or you know someone
that knows a coach ask questions
get in the air all the time um
and just whenever you play just put your
best foot forward never be afraid um
but the best thing about whatever i tell
players that want to um start you know
having a real good crack
the best way for a coach to notice you
is to um get on your clips
if you don't if you don't do that you
just ask someone that might know and
just keep chipping away at coaches and
um just put your heart on solve out in
the field and just be ruthless
just get into it
go there and just smoke people that's
what
have you ever thought about getting into
motivational speaking because or like
speaking to young kids because that's
pretty inspiring yeah well no i'm not
really um
i'm not really good on speaking it's
better now even though jimmy's jimmy's
hut in here is like 30 degrees
the studio is pumping i'm wearing a
hoodie to try and sell some hoodies so
better give a swim
but
um no just yeah if you're a kid mate
just keep chipping away and just
don't be afraid to ask questions message
if you're a young boy nuts in college
you could message me you know that's all
good i'm there yeah
what about if you go to another school
would you be open to it 100 yeah kidaway
man or even in christchurch school any
school you can message
anyone and um if they're a great guy
they'll message you back if they're not
they mention some other one
your phone's going to blow up over the
next few weeks people wanting advice or
inspiration from you but that's cool
that you're willing to put your time in
there and yeah help anyone become
be in your shoes i guess
that's just one of those things i i i
was fortunate enough to have a lot of
people around me playing rugby so i just
think the way to keep it going is to
give the same experience back to other
people pay it forward yeah mate you are
an absolute lad
absolute honor having you on the podcast
mate i'm glad to get you on i know a lot
of people wanted this for a long time
you're a bit hesitant but great to have
you on giving some insight into your
journey to where you are now and no
doubt you're going to have a massive
future so i'm sure everyone who's
listened to this podcast will also look
forward to following your future and no
doubt we will see you on that black
jersey at some point down the line but
really appreciate you coming on the
podcast mate thank you very much
[Laughter]